USING #NBACARES TO LEARN MORE.
CARES.NBA.COM.
LAKERS NOW ON 8-0 RUN.
>> Reggie: FUELLED BY THEIR
DEFENSE, BRIAN.
>> Brian: BRIDGES.
TOUGH SHOOTING NIGHT CONTINUES
FOR BRIDGES.
JAMES WITH ANOTHER REBOUND.
LeBRON'S GOT FIVE BOARDS NOW.
HERE'S CARMELO ANTHONY, LITTLE
SIDE DRIBBLE.
AND NOW ANTHONY'S GOING TO GET A
T.
HE THOUGHT HE WAS FOULED, HE IS
REALLY UPSET.
AND THE THIRD TECHNICAL OF THE
NIGHT.
>> Reggie: OH, YEAH, RIGHT TO
THE MIDSECTION, RIGHT AS HE WAS
GOING UP.
HE FLEW BY -- JAE CROWDER FLEW
BY BUT CAME BACK WITH HIS LEFT
HAND AND JUST KIND OF FLAILED AT
THE MIDSECTION.
>> Brian: CARMELO ANTHONY IS
OUT, SECOND T OF THE NIGHT.
TWO Ts FROM ANTHONY, WESTBROOK
GOT ONE EARLIER IN THIS GAME AS
WELL.
>> Reggie: BRIAN, THAT'S A WIN
IF YOU'RE MONTY WILLIAMS AND THE
SUNS.
BECAUSE MELO'S BEEN SO
CONSISTENT AT BEING ABLE TO
SHOOT THE BASKETBALL FOR THIS
LAKERS TEAM.
NOW YOU TAKE THAT THREAT OFF THE
FLOOR HERE.
SEE IF TREVOR ARIZA CAN CONTIN